squaring off against james caprilian
making his 17th start
of the season coming off a very gutsy
gritty type outing against the san
francisco giants where he'd go five
innings surrender just one run did have
four free passes and again these would
end up winning that ball game but
kite tonight he squares off against a
white hot new york yankee lineup and it
will be a good test for mr caprilia well
the yankees going for a dozen they'd
like to have 15 in a row when they leave
oakland but they have an 11 game winning
streak their longest winning streak
since 1985.
and on three pitches la mayhew swings
and misses a good start for caprolia
three fastball so here's anthony rizzo
one of the new yankees
murphy sets up outside here's the pitch
and rizzo swings and misses on a fast
ball two strikeouts to begin the game
both of those on fastball's 95. so two
outs and here's aaron judge cat legs up
high open stance and caprillion
here's the pitch and aaron judge takes
on the inside corner fastball ring him
up strike three called
what a start for caprilian three batters
and three strikeouts we'll be taking on
the right-hander jameson tion who has
tied it on the second half has been
throwing the ball very well for the pin
stripers
swing and a miss cannon down on strikes
well that was a nasty hook for the
strikeout the way this game is going you
got to wonder if anybody's going to put
the ball in play now here is starling
martay and he hits a high fly to center
not deep
now gardner actually comes in a few
steps to make the catch two-way chester
shella on the left side tie onto the
plate and swing on it popped up gonna
carry the medium left and gallo kind of
ambling toward the line he's right there
and he makes the catch and so the a's go
down one two three and after one first
of a four game series the a's and the
yankees no score here's joey gallo he's
had unbelievable success against
caprilian
strike three
well you could see
titsner has a very wide strike zone he
punched out gallow
and judge on pitches that were clearly
outside and so it begins
boone has already been thrown out so
he's going to get his money's worth
with todd titular
you know this shows that manager cares
this is an important series the yankees
have a chance to put oakland further
back in the rearview mirror so here is
stanton
that one is driven to center field and
deep
really deep i mean really deep see ya a
long home run for stanton and the
yankees are on the board one nothing
giancarlo
nosy
parlo now when stanton hits him they
stay hit for a while and i like his
reaction like he knows this is not
coming back nobody's catching this one
maybe a fan five outs for caprilian five
strikeouts here's brett gardner and the
pitchers hit in the air to deep right
field down the line fair it's gone and
it is gone
it's fair and it's gone
let the guardy party begin rhett gardner
drills one down the right via line so
guardi goes yardy and the yankees take a
two-nothing lead looked like caprilia
was trying to sneak one over the inside
corner got too much of the plate gardner
was ripped and that'll bring up rizzo
just looking for a decent fly ball
anywhere if you don't get a base hit
velasquez has a good speed at third he
should be able to score that'll get a
run in
it'll move back harrison it's going to
be off the glove of harrison and it
rolls to the wall
velasquez scores easily it's an rbi
double for rizzo and it's three nothing
yankees well off the bat you knew a run
was going to score
you weren't quite so sure there's going
to be a hit involved harrison playing
him too cheaply in left field gets
burned
first walked off caprellian and yankees
have first and second with one man out
swung on hit high in the air to deep
right center that ball is high that is
far that is gone
joey jackson it is a three-run blast by
joey gallo
he's pal joey and the yankees now take a
six-nothing lead and the yankees are
pouring it on as they lead this one in a
big
big way on gallows 30th home run of the
season he doesn't hit light drive home
are you high
fly
balls 57 rbis for matt trying to snap an
o for 11.
and he smokes one to left and that
baby's gone bangs off the facing of the
second deck and the azer on the board
his 20th home run he snaps in oh for 11
and tries to awaken the athletics murph
with 14 homers and 54 driven in and the
big roddy back to the plate with the one
two
and that is blasted left center field on
its way way back
and sean murphy is headed out
the a's go back to back
and respond to the yankees
they now trail 6-2 murphy with his 15th
home run of the year that was about as
loud as it could be too 433 feet and
don't look now but the a's have the
tying run at the plate
and he missed outside what in that bet
by chapman
so a bases loaded walk makes it six to
three two outs for the birthday boy 33
years old today
up the middle base hit
harrison scores here comes moreland he's
gonna score at six to five the a's have
scored three times in the inning it's a
one-run game
attaboy elvis bases are loaded with two
out and the yankees who had a
six-nothing lead now lead six to five to
martay
and the pitch is grounded up the middle
grabbed by lemay who steps on second and
that will end the inning and that'll
bring up josh harrison that one's hit
that
well
gone josh harrison has tied it up with a
solo shot here in the fifth and these
have come all the way back pack your
bags jay hey all aboard next
a stop has struck out walked and struck
out there's a fair ball down the right
field line that's going to go into the
yankee bullpen judge rounds first he'll
go to second and he's going to make it
with a big lead off double he's going to
bring up giovanni urschela a big spot
for him he has missed 23 games with his
hamstring injury here's the pitch swung
on a ground ball a third chavanese left
has it goes a second for the force and
what a job by romo
tie game against the yankees and base is
loaded and one out and he gets out of it
and now with two out in a tie game wade
is over third that one has looped into
right field it's a base hit
wade will score
aaron judge with a bloop single a drive
in the seventh round and give the
yankees a one-run lead martay the time
run at second base two outs bottom of
the ninth
and that one is chopped to odor
and the yankees win again the yankees
have won 12 in a row it's their longest
winning streak since they won 13 in a
row in september of 1961.
[Applause]